again with casino it is extremely
heavily regulated
yeah right and you can win money so it
makes sense
that you can't have the risk of winning
money without losing money
yeah right but with gacha games come on
for some people though man like that png
is worth more than money to me
it is it blew my mind that it took like
i went in seriously how many why what's
wrong with you because that's
what happened in your childhood
serotonin because like i've never
cared about anything no
no no no no until those pngs came along
i've never cared about winning money
because like
you know to me money money has value
like
obviously like
[Music]
serotonin here when you win like a
[ __ ] character that you're actually
emotionally attached to you know what i
mean
because people who win money in casinos
they're not emotionally attached to this
money doubt
no no i've i've had friends who have had
actual you know proper gambling problems
as well
and i remember this my i knew a friend
in a university who
one day won like 10 000 pounds
in a casino right could have paid off
his student loans could have you know
could could have been
like completely debt three and within
within three weeks he had spent
the 10k ten ten thousand pounds on
gambling on
on gambling right and i asked him dude
you could have [ __ ] invested this
money
you could have used it like more wisely
you could have used it to better your
life why did you
spend it on gambling or why did you
spend it so easily and he said
because i didn't care about it because
he didn't earn it right because he
because he had no emotional attachment
to the money because he was just given
it so
to him it just felt like it is the
equivalent of just someone coming up to
you being like he's 10k yeah
a lot of these you know the serotonin
you get from these waifus three months
say you don't give a [ __ ]
well that's that's that's your
prerogative dude do you give a [ __ ]
about some of the games that you pulled
for and got that that lovely serotonin
hit like no but i
i i have a nice memory you know what i
mean i have i have a ghost just [ __ ]
like
like ah yes i remember the time i i had
a good experience playing
like all the gadget games i've played
otherwise i wouldn't have played them in
the first place it's like you know going
to
it's like you know small basically the
same as like going to a [ __ ] arcade
or something right and like putting
money into that
no yeah yeah that's different yeah no no
it's different
it's like yeah you're only paying you
know maybe a hundred unit at a time but
it's still the same
it's like why is that what's the point
problem is that it's you could do 100
yen at a time and if i wanted to spend
500 bucks which i try to do yeah it
takes like five hours
like yeah for a long time if you want to
spend 10 grand on gacha
give yourself 20 minutes 10 grand in 20
minutes you
probably could if you were just buying
this the highest option
multiple speed running bankruptcy let's
go baby
like you could i'm sure you know like
like you see the streamers who spent
like
10 grand and but they're they're making
the money back yeah people who are doing
that who aren't making the money right
yeah and yeah some people are probably
in the financial position to be able to
do that
yeah but why even give yourself the
chance of like
making that happen to other people who
aren't right like you hear and again you
hear the horror stories of
kids spending their mother's money and
[ __ ] like that like why is this even
able to happen this shouldn't
there should always be a hard limit
built in that shouldn't be able to like
be able to okay let me let me ask you on
the person
let me ask you this what regulations
would you want to see then
what regulations how how did you fix
this problem that you've uh
that that you've presented when you
download the game
right and there is gacha in it there
should be an immediate question of what
is the maximum you're willing to spend
in like one year
and you physically no matter what you do
cannot go over that like it will
what if you said zero and then you
change your mind well that's on you
you've already said zero
isn't that the same as just putting in
the credit card numbers by yourself
anyway yeah
you've decided zero you then can't hurt
yourself more and you're stuck with the
thing because you agreed to zero
i think that should be a thing no
because like on on the
on the other side then that means
spending money in in essence is also on
you right
that you know that that's that shifts
responsibility from just one
place this is the problem like the
problem that people have with i think
when they're talking about like gambling
addicts is that
we don't think of it because we're not
gambling addicts we can't think of it as
why don't you just not spend money bro
that's not how it works yeah that's not
how it like this is the problem is that
i think people alienate these people and
don't even remotely think
how it is to be in their position right
right i totally understand but at the
same time it's
what i'm trying to say is obviously they
are there are people that are proper
gambling addicts
that have a problem that they you know
physically you know
like cannot control harder time to
control it's not
but how do you how do you introduce a
system where you know how do you
how do you introduce a system that can
regulate that
you know as opposed to you know other
people who have
you know no problem you know having
willpower and being able to control
their spending and financial decisions
i do think that there should be a hard
limit on monthly amount of money you can
spend on any game
i legitimately believe that i believe i
do not think that like
anyone should have any excuse to spend
over like ten thousand dollars on a
video game a month
like that should be just that should be
like a hard limit baked into the game or
app store
or something like that because no
realistically no one needs to spend over
a grand
yeah and if they do if everyone's
playing by the same thing if no one can
spend over the
grand the devs won't make games that are
able to get benefit of spending over a
grand you know what i mean
like i don't understand why there hasn't
been some kind of like hard limit on
video game spending
like that because why would the devs why
would they mean it's in the
game it's best interest yeah i know like
i i that's
that's probably the best solution i can
like agree on because i i do feel like
there should be a hard limit on how much
you can spend i think there also should
be something again with like how you can
say i want to quit like casinos
because you know gambling addicts
probably aren't gambling at it
24 7. it's probably like a lapse of like
willpower where they're like [ __ ] i need
to gamble some
yeah i'm depressed or something i don't
know how it works but there should be
something
in the system that's like okay i want a
gamble all right and then
you can say that or at one point when
you download the game say i don't want
to gamble you can only change this in
say
seven days of like are you sure so you
say yes i want to gamble all right
come back in seven days if you're sure
you want to gamble we'll let you gamble
right why not something like that
developers because
because most of the money i better spend
is
everybody everyone's moment of weakness
where they're like you know [ __ ] i'll
spend a hundred bucks come on let's see
what i get come on yeah you know what i
mean
most i mean how often would you spend
100 on the gotcha if i had to ask you
joey come back in seven days tell me you
still want to spend 100 bucks
and i just wouldn't bother with playing
the game at that point you'd play it
free to play
yeah or not or not play played at all
yeah i mean i i say
more than anything i'd probably not play
it at all yeah maybe what if you can't
spend money
in the game well no if i'm [ __ ] like
if i'm persistently being asked like are
you sure are you sure you want to do it
i'm just like i'm not even going to
[ __ ] bother with her then
that was that intrusive what do you mean
you won't let me spend my money i'm
furious it's like leave me alone i'll
spend it if i want to spend it it's like
the opposite now where they're like
spend money spend money yo get this pack
get this package
yeah and i'm like and i'm at a position
where i'm like i'll get the pack if i
feel like getting the pack
but i'm not going to feel like the same
thing what do you mean you could just
say no to the money thing
yeah you literally just said the same
thing
but you're just being an [ __ ] now
i literally just gave you the opposite
situation where like spend money spend
money and you're like i don't i'm fine i
don't want that yeah
so what's the difference i'm saying no
what
i'm gonna go like you're just playing
devil's advocate just to piss me off
yeah i love pissing you off
it's my favorite hobby